the pandemic is dramatically changing
our everyday lives as we continue our
series the new normal we look at how
those changes will affect the way we
work
socialize learn and vote president Trump
says going back to school is something
state governors should seriously start
to consider but it's not clear what
school will look like when students
return John King was education secretary
under former President Obama now he is
the president and CEO of the Education
Trust good morning mr. secretary in your
view what needs to happen before kids
can go back to school well we've got to
be guided by the best public health
recommendations and those include 14
consecutive days of declining cases
first in the community getting in place
a good system of testing and contact
tracing and then we've got to have
careful planning for how we reopen
school in a way that is safe for staff
and for students what do you think
reopen schools will look like I mean in
China there in some cases there are kids
are wearing masks and there are glass
dividers people are talking about
one-way hallways what do you think a
realistic scenario would be at this
point well assuming that we've got in
place that good system of testing and
contact tracing I think we're going to
see school districts needing to adapt
the structure of the day fewer students
in each classroom procedures for lunch
that will look very different where
students are eating in the classroom
rather than in cafeteria rethinking
activities like physical education so
that students aren't crowded into a
small space together they'll need to be
personal protective equipment for
teachers will need to make sure that if
a student becomes sick there's a way for
the student to be temporarily isolated
at school before they can be picked up
and
and they'll need to be processes in
place to regularly check students health
that may look like temperature checks a
certainly mass may be a part of the
strategy
that's what districts need to start
planning now for what will look
different when kids come back so how far
in your what's your feeling about how
far away from this we are well it
probably varies across the country
depending on where communities are in
the in the spread of kovat 19 but we are
so far from the fundamental testing and
contact tracing system that we need in
place as a country and that's that's
really the the most critical issue we
see from our international peers that
it's testing and contact tracing that's
the key to protecting public health you
brought up a really important point that
we may end up having effectively a lost
generation of kids here that during this
period inevitably so many children are
gonna be learning less and are at risk
of falling behind
how significant do you think that is
it's a huge risk and really what's
happened is the koban 19 crisis has held
up a mirror to our system and shown us
the extent of our inequities there are
some kids who don't have access to
devices don't have access to bandwidth
low resource districts that are
struggling to provide professional
development and support to their
teachers students who are experiencing
really difficult situations at home and
need more social emotional support and
so we see a real gap between what's
happening from one community to the next
some communities parents are able to
support their kids while they're home
teleworking other communities parents
have to work outside of the home and in
the African American workforce only
about 20% of folks are able to work from
home so we're going to see very large
academic gaps when students come back
it's why we need to be thinking about
potential summer school extended school
day with after-school programming
probably summer school
summer 2021 we've got to make sure that
we don't end up with out with a lost
generation of students and that's a
question of political will are we
willing to make the investments
necessary to protect students all right
so much as state secretary King thank
you so much for being with us this
morning